I'm Christopher Hein uh today with me is
Sensei gilmy yard
um did I say your name correctly
um and uh actually I'm going to let you
tell everyone uh kind of uh where you
come at in Aikido and daitorium
um so I've started when I was in 19th
um 15 or so uh had done Judo like you
know many French people of my generation
you you would have done Judo or soccer
and I was just not good enough at soccer
so I just you know I did that for some
years I think I went to EQ
uh and then got to be tired with
competition uh you know and then you
know went into uh into Aikido
mainly for two for tourism one is that's
absence of competition which was quite
appealing to me because I had already
done so much of it in Judo and I had
done the water photo as well I don't
know if she is oh yeah we have it yeah
right okay and uh so lots of competition
here as well so that was a good time for
me to switch I was in that sort of head
State and the fact that Aikido relative
to Judo and karate was a less uh
less well known so there was that sort
of mystery thing Associated to it the
hakama and all that so that sounded
great so that's what I started
um done that in a few countries France
uh I lived in England in Ireland
uh then decided to move to Japan and
it's when I first arrived in Japan that
I got the opportunity to uh
practice dietary for the first time
uh I found it quite interesting
um
didn't necessarily intend to continue
but I was kind of encouraged by my
Senpai whose name is Olivia Goa who's
somebody who's been in Japan for a long
long time and he's really pushed me to
continue and then I have continued uh
ever since
uh and that's yes probably now uh 14
years
um so yeah so starting negative 15 14
years of data you so I'm at a stage
where uh both those disciplines are as
much uh part of my identity uh I guess
um at this stage and and I find this
interesting because I think this is
really what ideally uh it should be what
you do should be part of you it
shouldn't be you so in other words you
know if for whatever reason you have to
stop at kilo because you get injured it
should not destroy you personally right
because you know this is not who you are
but it's really a part of you then you
could allocate that time and energy to
something else which uh if this happened
to me you know I have so many things I
like to do that that wouldn't be a
problem but it's about it's part of me
and um and and it's important in the
sense of uh
you know making make that leap through
your Technique through when you're on
the mat uh a weapons is a good example
uh you know like when you take your fork
and you eat that that fork is part of
you you don't think of the technique of
eating your your meal with your forks
just pick up the fork and it could be
your fork from home but it could be the
fork at the at the cafeteria and it
wouldn't matter with it uh so weapons is
the same thing for me it's just part of
you something that you you know so
intimately that you don't even think
about it uh and likewise empty-handed
technique is sometimes they're
dissociated from that sort of feeling we
kind of recognize that in weapons but I
think MTN techniques are like that as
well and every new partner is just a
different Fork when you go to the
restaurant
so yeah just to say that yeah at that
stage uh when I say it's part of me I'm
not making a big claim saying that I
know so much that yeah this is mine no
I'm saying that you know I'm I'm
comfortable in doing this uh enough
right so yeah that's that's about it
okay sounds great
um one of the reasons I really wanted to
talk to you was uh I had read several of
your articles and and over years you
know like so you know first you were
just the guy with the complicated name
that I didn't know how to say you know
um and then I was like oh I keep seeing
that guy's stuff coming up and I read
more things that I like stream you and
and one of the things I like about you
is you have a lot of humility and and
understanding of what you don't know and
acceptance of what you don't know and I
feel like in aikido right now we're full
of So Many Masters there's so many
people who know everything about Aikido
and they want to tell you exactly how it
is and and you know you you don't have a
small resume you have a nice resume of
what you've done but in that you're not
saying like oh I'm the actual expert and
if you really saw the Masters then you
would know like I know the real truth
like you have a very open uh Viewpoint
and I appreciate that and so I think
it's nice to talk with people who
clearly are experts in in Aikido and the
areas around Aikido yet they're they
don't they they recognize that they
don't don't know everything right and
and I appreciate that about you and um
one of the articles I read that you had
put together was a translation actually
of an old interview that uh yoshiba had
done in a in a magazine and it was this
really kind of contentious interesting
article and I had read some other stuff
around that and
you did not seem to like cherry pick it
and make it make it seem like you were
trying to cast a specific light on it
but you were you were giving a very open
translation I thought and it allowed me
as the reader to kind of take away what
I would instead of what you thought I
should take away and I appreciated that
a lot about you
um and so one of the questions I kind of
want to ask you is
um
yeah aikido's so diverse and so strange
and and different for different people
and you could do I get on one school and
then do it in another and they're
completely different things it seems
like what do you feel is the thread that
ties all of that together what makes
Aikido Aikido
um
um just before before and saying this
I'll just pick up on what you said about
the that translation
um and then linking to what you said
before
um
it's not necessarily because I put
something out uh that I understood it
fully
um and likewise on the subject of
translation that's an important point to
make I think
uh when I pick up a document and I
translate it it is translated with my
own limitations
and there are many parts to be perfectly
honest with you that I'm iffy about
especially of course on that particular
injury so only to to translate not
literally but to translate intelligibly
what is written
can be challenging let alone telling you
what Austin say might have meant
when you said that and I think this is
what's crucial is that you know yes I
mean anybody who's better a Japanese
than you will pick problems with uh the
translation that I do for sure and
that's why you know and and
Japanese is such a horrible language for
that because there's numerous elements
that come into play
not necessarily only literal translation
but also the context
whether or not you know a person when
you translate their words or is going to
affect your translation I have an NF
openly admitted this even when I
interview a Japanese instructors
especially those who I know well they
may be saying something in Japanese
I'm gonna translate it slightly
different because I know what they mean
and so
but as long as you're honest in in in in
saying that this is what you do I think
that's all right uh and I think as long
as I mean I'm trying to be truthful in
the way that I try to to pass on what's
being said uh is it the most accurate
I'm not sure and this is why most of the
time I when I can I I put the original
Japanese uh alongside so that people
actually can check and correct me if
need be I'm actually surprised to be
honest with you that I'm not corrected
more often uh it I should be really to
be honest I should be I'm making way
more mistakes than that uh so is it easy
a question of of Interest I mean a lot
of people who
who've got the skills necessarily don't
necessarily have the time and so on but
at least it's out there and it's subject
to to review and and this is something
that we are doing with uh Stan's work
uh Stan has done so much work but
nowadays we know a few things more uh we
can go back to the text and there's a
back and forth between me and Josh gold
constantly because sometimes we find
stuff and and we it doesn't doesn't
negate with standard but it puts it puts
more information it it it corrects a few
things and that that's that's the way it
should be I mean that comes from my
background in research uh scientific
research
there's never you know it doesn't matter
who says it it's it's what's being said
and is it is there evidence to back it
up and that's basically my my Approach
um as far as the your actual question
excuse me as to what what should I do be
um I mean
you can you can you know go through what
uh oceans is supposed to have said and
and written through the years until your
eyeballs bleed and and not really
necessarily find a satisfying answer
after all these years looking into it
what I can tell you is um
I think he just probably didn't really
mind
uh what would happen afterwards because
if we just look at his life
and that the various things that people
did in his school
uh I can't recall any incidents of him
telling you are not doing it right stop
doing that or or you'll become you know
hormone you'll be kicked out
that would happen uh very easily in in
so-called traditional schools
uh but that did not happen in Aikido
neither did he actually filter in the
people who came you know they said okay
anybody here can come and he didn't kick
out anyone
so I think if you just look at that
which is I think undeniable regardless
of what you might have written and said
it's what he did that leaves a lot of
wiggle room I think
um
for me Aikido being like part of that
big family of budo
um it is by nature uh something that
that's gonna have to uh to change to
evolve
to fit the time to fit the needs
um now where are the boundaries
either technically or philosophical
that's that's the actual question this
is uh partly why I want to study the IW
um I didn't study dietary you because I
wanted to well yes of course at the
beginning you want to know the real way
to do criticism and you know the real
way to do shiron again but then you
found out that there's so many ways to
do even within dietary school which is
not that monolithic thing there are many
ways to do I mean my own school we do
things very differently compared to what
uh what you guys see uh in the interview
in in the in a more I will say widely
available DVDs and stuff like that
but at least first it opens your mind
towards the fact that they are indeed
many ways to do things even in dietary
so immediately you change your point of
view in thinking whether somebody from
that school or that school does
something wrong to you it's not
necessarily wrong it's just we've done
differently and if you've studied enough
and if you know enough and you've got
the technical Keys vocabulary
to see the what I call points in the
technique I don't I don't use principle
I think it's a dodgy word it's too wide
it's like Keys it doesn't mean anything
um but the point in the technique if you
can see the point somebody's technique
even if it's not the way you do it in in
the Qatar in your school you say oh yeah
they are putting in action those points
and that makes sense and perhaps that's
not my choice but at least I can see
where that's coming from and why they're
doing it that developing that
intelligence that that ability to read
others those people's technique and
immediately what follows is tolerance
because first you admit that you don't
know everything and then you can see the
qualities rather than the difference in
other people's technique now what what
the human brain does it looks at
contrast
and it so it looks at differences to
make sense of the world unfortunately
that often is linked and I don't know I
mean the the the the the neural password
that says with these are probably you
know really interesting looking at
contrast sometimes Associated to uh
judgment and possibly negative emotions
uh that's very interesting something
about the human brain um but if you get
enough knowledge you don't you no longer
associate that with necessarily with
with negative emotion and you see Merit
instead which is why that is such a
literacy stuff is so important and I
encourage anyone to not necessary to
pick up diet or you I'm not here to say
that you know everybody should do that I
told you but at least you know going
cross-train and certainly different
schools like you know different teachers
I'm just amazed I'm just back from
Europe after a series of seminars and
I'm just amazed that nowadays
Aikido is still so segmented and people
still don't you know there's a seminar
of whoever it doesn't matter uh just
down the road and they won't go
uh because of their biased yeah I don't
I don't know what's is it is it fear is
it fear of the unknown is it fear of
differences you know something that
you you practice the technique you go in
a school and that feeling of this where
the technique is done like
hurts you almost in your identity or in
your conception of what it should be
and I think until you learn to let go of
that so the only way to do that is to to
do it more rather than less right right
and anybody who's you know done that
seriously enough and crosstrained enough
as as as understood that but there are
still a lot of people who are somehow
hurt and I use the word hurt
purposefully you know and I I do mean
that they probably feel negatively about
this
um and because it's not pleasant they
don't want to do it we have to find a
way to make them feel positively about
this so you know inviting each other and
so on I mean I mean here in in Japan I
try to do that for example I've got a
good um very good relationship with with
jackpayer in uh in Kyoto who's uh who's
a very very very prominent your thinking
instructor anuched issue of show that
goes all and and trying to establish
those bridges and we we you know we we
we communicate but also you know you got
me to come over to Kyoto and I would
like to to develop more collaborations
with him I think this is essential for
the for the Arts but still that doesn't
tell you what Aikido should be
um
what what I'm sure of uh the product of
what I've been doing uh indicted in
Aikido now when I step on the mat and I
do something I can explain to you
rationally everything I'm doing right
excellent and that's that's the only
thing if if your hands comes up during a
seminar class and somebody asked me why
are you doing this I can tell you
and I feel this is the essential thing
that the teacher needs to be able to do
uh do what you say and say what you do
in other words technically you must be
able to explain and justify everything
you do now you may change I mean during
my seminar I'm gonna I'm gonna you know
move the cursor from what you call like
uh new Aikido Dynamic Aikido to more
older technique and I'm gonna keep
changing the cursor depending on who
I've got in front of me what I want you
to teach on that day but it's always the
purpose the the product of a choice you
see I have chosen to put the cursor here
in that circumstances right and that
that's the way it should be now whether
your range is like this or like this
well it depends on how much training
you've done uh but within that range you
should be free to to do that uh because
if you only do something
not because you choose to do it but
because if you haven't studied the rest
then this is not a choice it's a product
of a limitation
uh so it's for me it's potential knowing
as much as possible and then I can
choose where I put the cursor
um and again as expected before it also
allows me to see the qualities in other
people like you know and that that
changes your life as well this is great
so that's that's what I could do is to
me
um
then knowing the historical technique I
can also say
uh and again you have to take that with
a pinch of salt because not all the
dietary School necessarily use the same
mechanics but I can tell you when
something goes against an essential
aspect mechanical aspect of what I told
you the way dietary works I can also see
it so I can tell you're making that up
because you know this is not really
fitting within the way it's done there
are so many ways to do you know the
martial arts
which are not uh
it's not a negative judgment I'm not
saying that it doesn't work or whatever
it's not the point just this is not how
dietary works as a whole
question
no I think it's a really complex
question and and I appreciate the way
you're answering it which is not just
giving
um a direct this is what it is you know
it is uh kodagai shinshionage and and
sugyashi you know like whatever whatever
ideas you have but it it's a complicated
answer and I think that's the problem is
for most people
um in the West in an internet culture
like they want an answer that they can
grab a hold of and then tell everyone
else well this is what Aikido is this
expert told me and now I know what
Aikido is and so we can write that off
um and and it's just not that way and
and for myself The more I've studied
Aikido the more
enigmatic it's become to me right
because I realize like well at the top
these people are both as legitimate and
they have different ideas about what
this thing must be so so it's it's not a
matter of legitimacy it's a matter of
why why are you making these choices and
earlier what you said about you think
the most important thing for a teacher
is to be able to explain why their doing
it that way that's how I would like to
see the consciousness of Aikido shift so
it's like it doesn't matter what you do
so much in that you can explain why and
why you're making those choices and um
and and so you know I I have this way of
saying like so and and we talked about
this in an email and it's my own pet
thing but to say that Aikido Zeitgeist
right like what is the spirit of Aikido
and to me it's kind of this amorphous
thing that like there's a feeling about
what Aikido is maybe Aikido is a refuge
for kids who were beat up a lot or maybe
Aikido is you know something like that
but it's like here's the thread that we
all have in common and here's how we're
trying to look at martial arts from the
lens that we all seem to have we all
seem to be these similar kinds of people
right and and it could be that amorphous
right but but I appreciate the way that
you're going about answering this
question which is I don't really know
but here's who I here's how I feel about
it and here's my expectations of other
teachers
and in many ways
um that sort of absence of competition
in Aikido is a blessing that is also a
curse
Because unless and I was lucky because I
came from that you come from an
environment very competitive environment
when you've had your you know I can tell
you in whatever it was far more violent
sometimes than you know the the question
classes that I that I do uh you know
after the match in the shower and the
plan and so once you've done the
competition and you've struggled like
this you you can tell that you decide to
move away from this otherwise and this
is why you know should people start
liking to do early in life I don't I'm
not quite sure or certainly not that
good only because if you haven't known
competition struggle like this
perhaps you cannot really recognize it
when it takes other forms and then in
Aikido because we've got that weird
grading system that's a mystery to me as
well like you know why would you have
that message of Aikido and and still
have a ranking system
what is the what is the point what
benefits uh
I would be in favor of tripping
stripping it away because this is where
competition goes you know did you get
your your need done before me and right
do I feel that you deserve it or do that
is more than here than you there is
competition uh likewise your position
with the teacher did you take more okay
meet and me uh you know this week from
the teacher and what does it mean does
it not like me anymore you know and so
that it's it's
it permeates in many aspects of Aikido
she's probably in many different other
disciplines as well and it's not only a
hero but we need to uh recognize uh when
it's there
uh but but this goes Way Beyond uh
Aikido but it's quite a destructive
force I think in in Aikido uh we have to
get rid of that and and find out that
you know it's a collaborative process
and it's a thing of self-growth uh what
does it matter you know to to be uh
better than the other and so on and
that's one of the relevance for me of
Aikido and in other words what makes in
my opinion Aikido Aikido is that it
would be a wonderful tool in my opinion
for society
to help people realize that uh
competition is really
um in my opinion a destructive force
competition is built in in our in our
DNA at the most fundamental level as one
of the competing the components of uh
Evolution via natural selection right
we've always been donors since it whole
thing started it's been competition from
the beginning to the end
perhaps now the species with a slightly
more developed in your context it might
be time to think along different lines
because what what's a winner
a winner is somebody who manufactures
losers so what is it telling you and
it's not my quote okay it's something
from a French scientist but I really
agree with that is it really the
relationship that we want to have with
each other
uh and you can you can apply that you
know you really do you really need that
competitive aspect for in business or
could a business run
without that's the sort of you know a
shock sort of mentality you know the
idea is about is growth sustainable in
in an environment which is basically
physically finite okay uh the
competition breaks down in those
circumstances when resources are limited
and so on because uh it's it's a
zero-sum game
what people win the others will lose
and I think I feel that Aikido could be
a wonderful Vector for this and that's
why I'm talking about it though uh the
really that's the The Wish by thing in
my opinion I can't see Target soccer
could be in much content with those
ideas
um it's been uh suggested that he might
have been but I think that's which we're
thinking we don't really have evidence
of it
um so that for me that that would be uh
would be very very important and I think
Aikido has a place for that uh and also
the the other part of that and that goes
back to what you were saying about
admitting our own limitations
is that
um doing all the martial arts uh you've
done I know that uh you know you you've
crossed trained in a number of things
uh teachers screw up uh you know
especially you know when you when you
when you you you do uh how would you say
uh free fight and stuff like that so
it's boring yeah
in Aikido we don't have that opportunity
and uh I'm very suspicious of teachers
who never make a mistake
uh because that doesn't happen does it
yeah the only way that happens is if
you've stacked the chances and if you've
fired the game to your advantage
and this is what the nikeido seminar
looks like most of the time
the teacher never makes a mistake the
teacher never fails
um and they should
uh and and sometimes I I screw with
people with like that
um I was showing a way to you know to
develop a bit of power on monetary
and it's something that is really
helpful to developer but there's a
there's a limit to that and I was
showing that in Britain uh just a few
weeks ago and I wanted to make a point
uh that you know this is not a
superpower so and I was very lucky there
was a wonderful gentleman
um a bodybuilder who had never done Ikea
in his life so he was not wearing any
keikogee and he just turned up and he
said I try and answer of course you can
and then I called that guy
and then I tried to do it and I can't do
it it's too strong it's not magic there
is a point where a technique is not
gonna work uh so first of all the
technique is absolutely not supposed to
work on everybody for sure and there's a
limit to physics yes okay obviously was
way more powerful plus you were smart
about it okay you could he knew how to
redirect his his body weight and so on
and that didn't work you should have
seen the the the the the the the shock
on people's eyes
when the Sensei failed it doesn't
compute it doesn't compute
and and I've done that in France as well
with the with the Judo teacher uh uh
quite strong but also very good at
reorganizing is is very important and
you just won't let you go down uh but
it's it's so it's so funny to see the
shock like people can't seem to process
that the information there's people are
gonna dismiss you oh yeah he doesn't
know anything it's failed oh I'm gonna
go back to my teacher who never fails
and you get the people who like what
just happened uh we need more of that
yeah we need more of that uh with so
no technique is 100 efficient nothing
works on everybody and and it's building
their life I mean it's that this is why
there are so many techniques in
daiquiryo for instance
uh this is why also takarasoka could
never show the same technique twice
because he knew that the second time
around he had somebody Smart in front of
win they will realize okay
learn to lose we need to learn to do so
right in other words we have to stop
competing in my opinion it's not to be
the best what's this notion of best
right the best word no no this is
nonsense
but at the same time we have to accept
to lose we have to learn to lose
[Music]
so I'm not you know to be very clear I'm
not suggesting we should include
competition in Aikido I am not saying
that but we should include that notion
of Deceit of failure and it's not here
enough I mean you play basketball you're
not gonna get it in the in the rim all
the time that's why you train how come
in in Aikido we we think somewhere
differently about this aroma so do you
think this is really the the Crux of the
problem you're describing where we we
are trying to have a martial art that's
not about competition and trying to show
there are ways other than competition
yet in the absence of competition we
expect like phenomenal results you know
in a judo instructor well people know
that they lost that Championship or they
did badly in that tournament and so it's
obvious but that doesn't take away from
the fact that we know he's still good
judoka but in Aikido because we have the
absence of competition and in fact what
we're trying to do is teach
non-competitiveness there's this
inherent problem this that's happening
all the time exactly exactly that's
exactly what it is in my opinion
um it's it's the most beautiful thing
about it you know but it's at the same
time this is where this is the root of
so many of its uh its problems which is
why that that the honesty is absolutely
necessary uh and I'm not always seeing
it I mean let's be honest a lot of
people are very honest but
do I mean in other words uh one of the
claims of this and that teacher if we
say that Aikido should be diverse okay
teacher who should be claiming things
that uh I don't agree with
and I should be fine with it as long as
they deliver on those
question is do they do that and it goes
both ways now if you claim that Aikido
is that uh
super efficient combat system well then
show it right
um but at the same time if you said that
Aikido is that education system
to become a better person well show it
right because I can tell you there are
many people who claim that Aikido is
that you may sell different this time or
whatever and they wouldn't last a single
second in the suburbs in Paris
and there are those people who claim
that Aikido is an education system to
make you a better human being and they
are Dreadful human beings right when you
know them they're awful in Japan and
abroad some of the the the most
prominent teachers
who are into that kind of thing
are absolutely not nice and easier so is
are they are they doing what they're
what they claiming to be doing
and that should be held accountable but
at the same time you know my clients in
age though you shouldn't be accountable
for my claims in aikido right I mean if
somebody comes to you and say hey uh you
know Aikido is supposed to be this and
they tell you but this is not what you
said you see something that I said why
would you be held accountable for that
you don't have to right so in in many
ways you know there are many claims but
I don't feel accountable for those but
for sure you know if you pull something
that I've said
and you tell me look you know are you
actually doing what you said yeah uh I
might one have changed my mind or I
might indeed not been doing what I've
said and uh you know that should be uh
highlighted for sure
awesome I really appreciate your candor
and vulnerability and I think in Aikido
particularly it's a hard thing to have
because as you said when you show
vulnerability in Aikido everyone tends
to go oh well they just don't know the
real secrets you know right I appreciate
that I appreciate that and it's nice to
see someone who's come a long way in
Aikido being able to have that so I I
appreciate you quite a bit thank you
very much
thank you well I mean
um I've you know I've seen a lot of very
very very good uh teachers some of the
best in the world
uh so I think even though I myself may
not be able to do
many things
I probably have a good sense of what you
can expect to achieve in one or the
other sort of interpretation of Aikido
and I think if you if there is one thing
I can you know I I can claim from my uh
background
is that I've seen a great deal of people
uh
High ranked in numerous disciplines so I
think I've got a sense of what what
potential there is uh and uh you know
the the benefit and the cost sometimes
of doing this or that I mean I know uh
that that thing of uh you know it's a
very popular time the past 10 years of
internal power internal power
everybody's only about internal power
and uh
it's good uh but do I want to spend a
seminar uh doing it again and doing this
for two hours no it's not me it's not me
and and you know is is spending all that
time something that's to develop those
qualities something that's really uh I
find interesting as a whole no there are
so many other aspects in the mind is the
timing there's so many other aspects I
try to Encompass uh all of it and also
uh you have to look at the cost of of
something you do I mean it's it's really
interesting that some of the
practitioners which were the most
talented which are the most talented in
developing insane amount of
they refer to it as internal products
well I'll use it even though I don't
really use the time myself
but you know the physics is is you know
is a if you generate power insane
amount of power physics says so that
some of it is going to go in whatever
you're striking but
alphabet is going to go back to you
right and a lot of people who are
working on onslow's line don't
necessarily consider that fact
until they injure themselves they don't
get injured okay I got injured trained
no no you injured yourself you're
generating so much energy that come back
to you
and you haven't really necessarily
considered what to do with it
and you've damaged somewhere in your
body and I've seen that many many times
you see that in weapons as well because
immediately with weapon because you get
additional weight and momentum to what
you do
a lot of people who train like with the
Freebo you know the the the the the very
heavy uh
and so that that can go up to eight
eight kilo or something ridiculous like
this uh what what is it for well it
precisely this is not something that you
use to develop power it's an additional
uh load that you have to learn to deal
with internally with your body and if
you're already you're not good at doing
your suburi with a normal standard octo
and you find that at the end of your
strike there's always that little bit of
tension at your back of your spine uh
towards your hips because you tend to
compensate that extra momentum
times hundred thousand ten Thousand Cuts
it will build up to inflammation and to
damage now pick up that thing which is
now eight kilos and do the same mistakes
you're not building internal power
you're you're crippling yourself right
uh and that does interestingly I don't
find that you see lots of articles
uh about your internal power and how to
develop in and what you supposed to do
their pictures and stuff
rarely do people actually mention the
fact what the heck do you do with that
power once you generated
um so that that's one of the other thing
and I see people for that reason
I I got injured practicing Aikido no no
no no no most of the time you enjoyed
yourself
it's a nice distinction
um okay
um is there anything else I mostly what
I wanted I wanted to touch base with you
and I wanted to
um uh kind of expose uh my audience a
little bit to your ideas I really
appreciate your translations and the
work you're doing
um and so if you have anything else
you'd like to add uh that would be great
otherwise I I got the Mainstay of what I
wanted to talk about in this interview
although I'd like to maybe do something
with you in the future if you have time
that would be wonderful for sure for
sure I mean I I realized that my answers
or perhaps not very uh satisfying in the
sense of of actually answering because
I'm
I refrain precisely from uh from giving
a specific answer
um now of course when I teach or when I
practice I make choices so if you like I
go down the path uh very very specific
past
um but that will depend on the of the
circumstances uh and which is it's also
was it's nice to have that range
sometimes I start I start a seminar and
I and I've got the intent of going all
Dynamic and
is not that good
it's nice to be able to to shift
when you realize that instead of you
know being like Oh what should I do um
you know six hours of this exactly you
know like the seminar just started it's
a whole weekend and it's Saturday
morning what am I gonna do uh so it's
it's part of General culture and um I
think
Aikido culture is is something which is
necessary uh which is why in my in my
articles in my videos when I interview
somebody when I can I always try to put
the the context the background give some
indications culturally linguistically
so that people can understand who those
people are about